julie casimir je suis là tu es là et
vous aussi facteur voilà il se passe
quelque chose d'épouvantable
je me souviens de rencontrer françois il
m'a annoncé la venue dans l'île de
l'ignoble monsieur travelling encore sur
ce monsieur travelling exagère il faut
le mettre hors d'état de nuire à vous
qu'est ce que ça veut dire nuira ça veut
dire faire du mal très bien il faut
absolument empêcher cet individu de
m'enfermer dans une cage et de me
promener comme un hymne violent et
horrible gros monstres ne t'inquiète pas
casimir nous allons trouver le moyen de
le mettre hors d'état de nuire nous
avons le prendre à son propre piège
je ferai comme au recteur avait ça a
voulu vous verrez
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
si tu reviens de chine tu veux tu nous
proposes tu me la télé les maps
[Musique]
vous êtes avant tout est prêt bon
voyons monsieur casimir voilà refaite
moins de
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
bodio mais on fait comment voulez vous
que je la demande comment le père est
allé avec des artistes qui se donne même
pas faire voir l'ua or vous n'envoyez
avoir au total et que le sol soit aussi
doux que la caresse du vent dans les
arbres en fleurs loeb l'étrange allez je
vous salue rice avait pas de temps à
perdre 1 200 m avec savez-vous moi qui
vous parle et excusez moi mais je viens
de très loin
ça je m'en serais douté mais je puis
vous affirmer que vous parlez au roi de
l'opérette marseillaise ah oui oui
escartefigue garrigue auteur chanteur
compositeur pour vous servir très honoré
monsieur garder nos yeux doux à 19 après
sarrio de l'imprésario et précis si
justement j'aurai besoin de quelqu'un
qui puisse me faire faire le tour du
monde
vous voyez ce que je veux dire est que
ça rapporte vous connaissez quelqu'un
mais moi je suis déguisé mais en vérité
je suis albert travelling le plus grand
après sa yo di mauro mêlant qu'à cela ne
tienne je travaille et je vous en prie
asseyez vous sur le banc là vous serez
très bien qu'on allait poser je vais
vous chanter une chanson sur la vocation
des facteurs clés comme votre ami aura
perdu
[Musique]
j'aurais pu être plombier zingueur
meunier maçon ou gêne au gras
j'aurais pu même être chauffeur
j'aurais pu un tout petit bassin coffees
mécanographe
mais j'ai choisi d'être acteur
car je suis là ouah jal d'orthographe
je suis l'ami et joliment
amoureux des phrases et ses vidéos
[Musique]
emporte sur mon
seul un penchant
j'aurais pu être plombier zingueur
meunier basson rouge et au bras
j'aurais pu même être chantre
j'aurais pu être cultivateurs confiseurs
ou mécano draps
mais j'ai choisi d'être acteur
je suis le roi de l'orthographe
dès que comment ce matin
tout le long du chemin je chante
les gens guette mon arrivée cela mon
jean
[Musique]
à
à la fin
je vais plus à combiers zager veniez
masson rouge et au drame
j'aurais pu même être un chanteur
j'aurais est cultivateur confiseurs pour
mecha l'eau
mais j'ai choisi d'être pack fer forgé
je choisis des tracteurs pour sûr
mais j'ai choisi d'être un pasteur
[Musique]
albon sentent comment un très bon
chanteur j'allais me dit que je suis un
formidable un excellent
remarquable chanteur avait raison voici
un contrat je vous engage comme sentait
pas question
pourquoi pourquoi parce que c'est moi
qui vous engage attendait tout est
renvoyé je vais aller chercher un stylo
bas un stylo
voilà voilà monsieur travelling
attendait j'avais signé
voilà ici
à vous maintenant et non pas de se garer
que c'est normal
à
[Musique]
huit mois préparez vous car nous partons
dans un quart d'heure un sage sonic ton
pardon jette vos dents et 1000 et 1100
hyde le facteur
casimir quelques mois les un peu à
monsieur travelling le contrat qu'il a
signé avec plaisir parce que vous avez
signé mais pas bling mois alberta bling
je m'engage à ne plus venir chercher
casimir
à ne pas me laisser gagner six jeux si
je tentais encore de lui faire signer un
contrat
celui ci aurait le droit de me promener
à travers toute l'île a enfermé dans une
cage comme un gros nom est horriblement
[Musique]